peu
[Musique]
peu pour des matchs
une caresse pour des
si tu veux te réchauffer
faut savoir bien ruiner
et pourtant
c'est pas bon
c'est bon
c'est pour eux
si le doubien pas
super ça a payé et que tu cherches à
tamise
on m'a dit va te chanter c'est bon
un pneu
c'est là
c'est bon pour le moral c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
bon si tout paraît
pour compléter
il ya mieux
gentil mais c'est bon
c'est pas pour le moment
c'est pas pour demain
c'est pas l'heure
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon
[Musique]
c'est pas
quant aux leurs
c'est pas pour le
c'est important
c'est pour eux
pour m
bucarest pour décoller
si tu vas te le mettre
ça va bien mais c'est pas pour
ces mamans
enfin
m
vous les voulez
c'est lancé
quand ses lacets
[Musique]
les rouler
car c
c'est
c'est bon pour
c'est pour eux
[Musique]
c'est bon
pas pour la
c'est pas faux
c'est bon
c'est pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]